i'll tell you the reason that mirrors  are in elevators and it's not what you  think the reason they put them there is  that people started complaining about  them being slow they didn't like the  music there's many things that people  didn't like about elevator rides right  it's boring what they did is they put  mirrors on the walls and so then all of  a sudden people are fixing their teeth  they're fixing their hair they're alone  and they completely forget about the  music that's on the color of the  elevator how long it takes because  they're so obsessed with themselves and  that's the example of a logical versus a  psychological solution they can always  use to approach a problem